giga rencontré patrick est sans aucun
doute le plus grand fan que johnny est
au monde son appartement est le reflet
fidèle de son idolâtrie
[Musique]
j'ai vu johnny pour la première fois
j'avais j'avais 6 ans ton palais des
sports en 71 j'ai toujours connu de jeu
nice ya jamais eu autre chose que je
veux dire on ici chez moi en bois johnny
on mange denis on vit johnny pas c'est
c'est pas c'est pas une passion c'est
carrément une religion et puis en plus
si vous avez un problème dans votre tête
tu ne nous aide pas bien tout ça ce qui
arrive des fois vous écouter un disque
où vous regardez une vidéo et puis tout
de suite ça va mieux en quelque sorte
genis et un grand docteur
les plis du drapeau
santé gym l'année
j'ai été présentée la première fois
johnny c'était en 75 et quand je suis
rentré dans dans la caravane et j'ai vu
une jolie devant moi ça ça fait bizarre
je veux dire il y avait beaucoup de
monde autour de lui mais je veux dire je
voyais plus personne c'est taxes étaient
de jolis il brillait au tour à vii et
noir
si la fiche de paie ça
pour moi la photo la plus marrant c'est
la photo qui a un mur c'est que
je n'y avait les cheveux blancs c'est à
l'époque de terminus puis moi ça me
plaisait tellement que j'ai voulu faire
comme une vraie je me suis fait
décolorer les cheveux je me suis rasé en
bronze comme lui et le problème c'est
que moi j'ai perdu mes cheveux en
faisant ça parce que je suis passé cinq
fois chez le coiffeur en quinze jours
ont fermé pour me faire des capés
car quand jeune il a lu ça tout ça dit
il faut arrêter tes conneries qui m'a
donné l'adresse c'est que johnny se
faisait soigner justement mais le
problème c'est que moi je ne pouvais pas
suivre au niveau finance
[Musique]